you
I think about food and categories I
think it's important that we eat a
balanced diet and that means lots of
fruits vegetables and whole grains
everybody knows that diets that are
based on those are associated with good
health and then meat and dairy if you
eat meat and dairy products you just
want to eat a lot of different kinds of
foods I don't think there's any one food
that anybody needs I can't think of a
single food that a single single food
that is absolutely essential if you look
at human diets across the entire world
you see the diet's vary enormously and
depend on what's available locally so
the whole business about you need to eat
this food or you shouldn't eat that but
that's all about marketing it's not
about health